I have made more money out of gold that
all the Great Frame brothers put
together you're still thinking about
it's a lovely bowl that if I can round
up the right people what kind of people
go on so as a new hip going kid okay hey
what miss deaf as a post packed the
gardens Easter no run at home we go down
the shaft like spider-man then through
the wall and the port is ours okay
we not do good greif they're killing me
Oh tell me anything while you're in that
movie huh the problem with cold it's
easy the game but it's difficult to get
rid of police upset this is the biggest
robbery in UK history everyone thinks
she lost you know well I don't want to
get cold again I'm not stupid
unless they're complete idiots the
jewels must have already left the
country those dingbats they've knocked
us all right on the governor now I'll
have you feel jerks so happy to give
everything you switched them yes I do
you want if anyone's the weak link is
for me your honor Kenny
yeah born Kenny damn Billy they're like
a pack of starving rice
[Music]
just so disappointed when people stooped
about seven
[Music]
the blowing leading the death he's dead
let's go to PI
[Applause]
[Music]
you